I haven't taken a homeopathic product called T Relief Artica for arthritis pain in my
risks caused from the immunotherapy. So understand, my belief with homeopathy is that homeopathy
can be fantastic. So we personally as a family use artica for pain, homeopathic artica,
you can also get an artica as an herb for pain as well. We use that for pain. My kids give
that to their, my grandkids, that's a main thing that they happened there. Arsenal, we
went on a family vacation, a number of weeks ago and my daughter and law had a homeopath
for artica and her son heard his ankle and first thing they gave him was artica for pain.
It works well to relieve the pain. However, I just noticed one of the active ingredients
is lactose. You don't have to worry about that. So I stop taking it as I know that there
it, don't worry about that. So you're not, you're not, not taking dairy because of the lactose.
So lactose is the sugar in dairy. There is not enough lactose in the homeopathy of
artica to even register in your, in your body. You're not, not taking dairy because of lactose.
It's not the lactose in dairy that is the suggestion for you to not take dairy. So go back and
use the article that's just fine if it has lactose. So it's the lactose that ingredients the
tablets save the as dairy dough. It's not. So understand dairy has lactose in it. But that's
not why I'm not having you do dairy is because of the lactose. Other things have lactose lactose
is just a sugar. So go back to take that.